order questions to the Prime Minister
other than one meeting this afternoon
with Her Majesty the Queen the diary for
the rest of my day is remarkably light
and I'm told that there are lots of
leadership roles out there at the moment
as the England Football team top gear
even across the big pond the role that
needs filling well first of all let me
say at the despatch-box how warmly I
congratulate the Home Secretary
when it comes to women Prime Minister's
I'm very pleased to be able to say
pretty soon it's gonna be 2 nil
and not a pink bus in sight and to be
accused of sloth in delivery by the
right honourable gentleman let's just
take the last week we both have been
having these leadership elections we got
on with it we've had resignation
nomination competition and coronation
they haven't even decided what the rules
are you talking of the economy the Home
Secretary again she said many people
find themselves exploited by
unscrupulous bosses I can't imagine who
she's referring to I have to say I'm
beginning to admire his tenacity he is
reminding me of the Black Knight in
Monty Python's Holy Grail he's been
kicked so many times but he says keep
going it's only a flesh wound I admire
that but before I before I ask him the
last question could I just put on record
and wish him well as he leaves this
office and also to wish his family well
Samantha and their children because I
think we should all recognize that
whilst many of us really do are enjoy
our jobs in our political life
it's the loved ones nearest to us and
our families that actually make enormous
sacrifices that we may be able to do
this so I'd also like him to pass on my
thanks to his mum for her advice about
ties in suits and songs I've done a bit
of research mr. speaker I have addressed
5,500 questions from this dispatch box
I'll leave it for others to work out how
many I've answered
and the rumor that somehow I don't love
Larry I do and I have photographic
evidence to prove it sadly I can't take
Larry with me he belongs to the house
and the staff loved him very much as do
I the Prime Minister came to office
promising to keep the UK's Triple A
rating to end top down NHS
reorganizations and to stop his party
banging on about Europe as no two people
know what brexit means at the moment we
need his advice and his statesmanship as
much as we ever had not many people know
this but actually his first act as
Chancellor of the Exchequer was too far
me as a special advisor and nothing is
really impossible if you put your mind
to it after all as I once said I was the
future once